>>> ON ROGER WATERS SOLO TOUR,
INSTEAD OF TURNING DOWN THE
POLITICS, HE'S AMPING IT UP TO
11.
LAST TIME, HE PREACHED AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP AND PAL TINE.
IT REFERS TO POLICE MURDERING
BLACK MEN, SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS
AND VIDEO SCREENS IN THE SHAPE
OF A CROSS.
WHY WATERS TOUR DIFFERS FROM
CLASSIC ROCKERS.
STONES OR MEMBERS OF THE
BEATLES, IT'S MORE A TRIP DOWN
MEMORY LANE THAN A CURRENT SHOW.
THE ACTIVISM IS A KEY TO THE
WHOLE THING.
AS A LONG-TIME FAN OF WATERS
MUSIC, I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT HIS
MIX OF PERFORMING AND PREACHING.
THINGS GOT A BIT ANIMATED.
SO, HERE'S THE QUOTE, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT TO BEGIN THE SHOW.
>> IF YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE, I
LOVE PINK FLOYD BUT CAN'T STAND
WATERS POLITICS, YOU MIGHT DO
WELL TO [ BLEEP ] TO THE BAR
RIGHT YOUR.
>> YOU MIGHT DO WELL TO GO TO
THE BAR RIGHT NOW.
THE OUTSET OF THE SHOW?
BECAUSE?
>> IT'S A REALLY GOOD WAY TO
START THE SHOW.
IT SETS A FEW THINGS STRAIGHT.
>> NAMELY?
>> WELL, IT ENCOURAGES PEOPLE
THAT COME TO THE SHOW.
THEY HAVE LISTENED TO EVERYTHING
I'VE WRITTEN SINCE 1965 OR
WHENEVER I STARTED WRITING.
THEY DO KNOW WHAT MY POLITICS
ARE.
THEY DO UNDERSTAND WHAT MY HEART
IS.
THEY UNDERSTAND WHY I'M THERE.
MAYBE IT GIVES A MESSAGE TO
PEOPLE THAT DON'T WANT TO BE
THERE.
THEM EFING OFF TO THE BAR IS
PROBABLY NOT A BAD IDEA.
EXCEPT THAT YOU NEVER KNOW.
THOSE PEOPLE, IF THEY SIT IN A
COMMUNITY LIKE MY AUDIENCE IS,
ON THESE SHOWS OF THIS IS NOT A
DRILL, THERE IS SUCH A GREAT
FEELING OF COMMUNICATION IN THAT
ROOM BETWEEN ME AND THE AUDIENCE
AND BETWEEN US COMBINED, WITH
ALL OF OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS,
ALL OVER THE REST OF THE WORLD.
IF THIS IS NOT A DRILL OR A
MESSAGE, IT'S THAT WE HAVE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH ONE OR ANOTHER.
>> TO THE GUY THAT SAYS, SHUT
THE EF UP, PLAY THE HITS, AS
LONG AS HE DOESN'T SHOUT IT OUT,
DO YOU WANT HIM IN THE ARENA?
>> I DON'T NOT WANT HIM THERE.
SO LONG AS HE DOESN'T ANNOY THE
PEOPLE THAT DO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE ARENA.
>> DO I HAVE TO BUY IN?
DOES A PERSON IN THE CROWD HAVE
TO BUY IN TO THE MESSAGE?
I HAVE ALWAYS LOVED THE MUSIC.
SOME OF THE MESSAGES I CAN BUY
INTO AND SOME I CAN'T.
>> I ONLY GOT ONE MESSAGE.
TWO STRANGERS PASSING IN THE
STREET AND IF THE GLANCES MEET,
IF I AM YOU AND WHAT I SEE IS
ME, THAT'S MY MESSAGE.
AND THAT WAS IN 1970.
AND MY MESSAGE HASN'T CHANGED.
I RECOGNIZE YOUR HUMANITY AND I
RECOGNIZE THE RUSSIANS AND THE
CHINESE AND THE UKRAINIANS AND
THE PALESTINIANS.
>> ARE YOU AN EQUAL OFFENDER ON
THIS TOUR?
I REMEMBER THE LAST TOUR.
I CAME AND WATCHED.
VERY MUCH ABOUT TRUMP.
IN THE CURRENT SHOW, A MONTAGE
OF WAR CRIMINALS TO YOU, AND A
PICTURE OF PRESIDENT BIDEN THAT
SAYS, JUST GETTING STARTED.
WHAT'S THAT ALL ABOUT?
>> JOE BIDEN IS FUELING THE FIRE
IN THE UKRAINE FOR A START.
THAT'S A HUGE CRIME.
WHY WON'T THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA ENCOURAGE ZELENSKYY TO
NEGOTIATE, MAKING THE NEED FOR
THIS HORRIFIC, HORRENDOUS WAR.
>> YOU'RE BLAMING --
>> WE DON'T KNOW --
>> YOU'RE BLAMING THE PARTY THAT
GOT INVADED.
YOU GOT IT REVERSED.
>> ANY WAR, WHEN IT START?
YOU CAN LOOK AT THE HISTORY.
YOU CAN SAY IT STARTED IN 2008.
OKAY?
IT'S -- THIS WAR IS
THIS WAR IS ABOUT THE ACTION
AND REACTION OF NATO PUSHING
RIGHT UP TO THE RUSSIAN BORDER,
WHICH THEY PROMISED THEY
WOULDN'T DO WHEN GORBACHEV
NEGOTIATED THE WITHDRAWAL OF THE
USSR FROM THE WHOLE OF EASTERN
EUROPE.
>> WHEN YOU SAY THIS, THEN I
HAVE TO SAY WHAT ABOUT OUR ROLE
AS LIBERATORS?
YOU OF ALL PEOPLE --
>> YOU HAVE NO ROLE AS
LIBERATORS.
>> WORLD WAR II.
>> YOU GOT INTO WORLD WAR II
BECAUSE OF PEARL HARBOR.
YOU WERE COMPLETELY ISOLATIONIST
UNTIL THAT SAD, THAT
DEVASTATING, AWFUL DAY.
>> I WOULD ARGUE WE WERE ALWAYS
GOING TO GET IN AND THAT PUSHED
US IN, BUT THANK GOD THE UNITED
STATES GOT IF, RIGHT?
YOU LOST YOUR FATHER IN WORLD
WAR II.
THANK GOD THE UNITED STATES --
>> THANK GOD THE RUSSIANS HAD
ALREADY WON THE BLOODY WAR
ALMOST BY THEN.
DON'T FORGET 23 MILLION RUSSIANS
DIED PROTECTING YOU AND ME FROM
THE NAZI MENACE.
>> YOU WOULD THINK THE RUSSIANS
WOULD HAVE LEARNED THEIR LESSON
FROM WAR AND WOULDN'T HAVE
INVADED UKRAINE, FAIR?
>> YOU WITH ALL YOUR -- I WOULD
SUGGEST TO YOU, MICHAEL, THAT
YOU GO AWAY AND READ A BIT MORE
AND THEN TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE UNITED STATES WOULD DO IF
THE CHINESE WERE PUTTING
NUCLEAR-ARMED MISSILES INTO
MEXICO AND CANADA.
>> THE CHINESE ARE TOO BUSY
ENCIRCLING TAIWAN AS WE SPEAK,
OKAY.
>> THEY'RE NOT ENCIRCLING
TAIWAN.
TAIWAN IS PART OF CHINA!
THAT'S BEEN ABSOLUTELY ACCEPTED
BY THE WHOLE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY SINCE
1948.
AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT,
YOU'RE NOT READING ENOUGH.
GO AND READ ABOUT IT.
>> OKAY.
DID WE SOLVE ANYTHING HERE
TODAY?
>> NO.
WELL, YEAH, WE DID.
I MEAN, NO, WE DIDN'T BECAUSE
YOU'RE BELIEVING YOUR
PROPAGANDA, YOUR SIDE'S
PROPAGANDA.
>> YOU'RE DEFINING IT AS
>> TAIWAN, YOU CAN'T HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS
AND YOU CAN'T HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT TAIWAN
WITHOUT ACTUALLY DOING THE
READING.
>> ROGER, IF YOU ARE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS,
AT THE TOP OF THE LIST OF
OFFENDERS ARE THE CHINESE.
WHY IS IT ALWAYS THE WESTERN
WORLD --
>> AT THE TOP OF YOUR -- THE
CHINESE DIDN'T INVADE IRAQ AND
KILL A MILLION PEOPLE IN 2003.
IN FACT, AS FAR AS I CAN RECALL,
HANG ON A MINUTE, WHO HAVE THE
CHINESE INVADED AND MURDERED,
SLAUGHTERED?
>> THEIR OWN.
>> BULLOCKS, THAT'S ABSOLUTE
NONSENSE.
COMPLETE NONSENSE.
YOU SHOULD GO AWAY AND READ, BUT
READ SOME PROPER --
>> HEY, MY PROBLEM IS I SPEND
TOO MUCH READING YOUR LINER
NOTES.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
>> THANK YOU FOR TALKING TO ME.
>> I APPRECIATE.
>> IT IS ALWAYS A PLEASURE.
>> IS IT?
OKAY